ok vous êtes ici dans une entreprise
privée
notre objectif à nous c'est que vous
donniez des jobs ready des personnes qui
soient capables de mener un entretien
d'embauché de pouvoir décrocher un
téléphone pour retrouver une offre
d'emploi de passer un entretien
d'embauché de le réussir surtout pour
justement créer de l'emploi si vous
dites juste pas j'ai raté mon bac et en
plus je cherchais un bout et ça marche
pas ça va être difficile
qu'est-ce qu'on pourrait mettre un petit
peu en attendant de qualité
ce compagnie dire que toujours à leur
contenu ou ponctuelles
c'est en train se empressement à un
recruteur sait si il va laisser sa
chance à la personne n'écoute pas douter
que vous allez me le dirait principal
défaut alors et jean qu'elle chantait
synthèse
quand j'en peux plus je peux être calme
hockey hebdo juste parce que je crois en
la personne qui s'occupe de se présenter
vous avez marre des jeunes il ne reste
que vous pouvez pas y aller vous
certainement rien n'est trop aller voir
le maximum de monde tous les employeurs
sont là il ya du boulot à la clé allez-y
je me suis je travaille trois quatre
mois ce serait bien mais je serai en
effet donc ça veut dire que si on trouve
un projet qui vous plaît vraiment vous
après vous pouvez tous les matins
candidate déterminé à bien préparer son
entretien
c'est quand même un bon retour non